[Music]
let's do a relationship advice it's been
too long since we did one sure my 35
male GF 32f
has been sending nudes to her her
married co-worker
so he's 35 she's 32. uh my girlfriend
went out tonight
with her sisters and friends for a b-day
dinner and she came home absolutely
drunk I've never seen so drunk before
what
long story short she went to bed and her
friends kept calling her to make sure
she was okay her phone was open to a
work email
and that is where I noticed her and her
co-worker were sending each other nudes
and talking through email for the past
two years titties in company email
yeah that's [__] wild that's bold I
open her work email dick in company
email that's crazy yeah that's [__]
crazy attachment yeah
that [__] that [__] is on those company
servers for just holding insert photo
attachment yeah
yeah or I'm gonna embed it in the email
that's so many key presses yeah that's
crazy I open her work email thousands of
messages going back two years pictures
videos her co-worker is also a 45 year
old married man I confronted her about
it and she is crying hysterically saying
that nothing physical has ever happened
between them but there there are
messages saying meet me in the back
hallway or meet me in the garage
right no they just wanted to fight yeah
yeah definitely
they both took a boxing class together
and they're just trying to yeah Spar you
know
uh I don't know what to believe she's
you don't know what to believe
she's saying she didn't cheat and that
she will quit
that is cheating
that it was just foreplay slash email
sex or whatever she just baby it was
just email sex
such a crazy thing yeah seriously not
really but
uh
uh kind of sucks will probably be a
process to kick her out
not sure if I want to continue the
relationship after this what is the best
way to go about this I mean bro you got
to get out just simply because the horny
you should break up with her via email
oh smart that's good that would be good
yeah to whom it may concern yeah yeah
we're done we're done
what do you think those messages about
meeting in discreet locations was
two people in close proximity to each
other for 40 hours a week don't exchange
nudes for two years or that [__]
those messages about meeting were
absolutely what you think they were
agreed she definitely physically cheated
yeah [__] duh yeah I mean my man yeah
I mean come on wake up dude they think
those messages were even about do you
think be honest with yourself what time
does the bacon narwhal yeah
I think she took some
what what I think he took some narwhal
in her bacon sleeve I don't know
whatever the [__] whatever bad pun
you've had some brutal two-word combos
today Rhino [__] and bacon sleeve yeah
that's gross sorry man sorry to break it
to you brother
listen man it's gonna be some tough love
here okay from one redditor to another
from a bearded scholar
[Laughter]
that's his nickname
but it seems pretty apparent that she
had relations with her co-worker okay
the evidence is right there okay
hard but you gotta accept reality okay
the fact that she lied about it okay and
didn't own up to it is enough to break
up in my book
okay but you have to do what you think
is best okay
ah she is lying about nothing happening
that voice send the messages to dude's
wife and break up with your girl
all these people just [__] you know
the dude who made up this post is
sitting there just laughing yeah yeah
she female 29 called me male 30 a [__]
when my dog died is it over I've had
this dog for 10 plus years since he was
a puppy
yeah why don't you cry about it loser
loser it was time to put him down as he
was old and very sick I was very sad as
you can imagine this dog was like a
family member to me his loyalty was
second to none
while as I was mourning his loss
in the days ahead I occasionally cried
expecting my GF of three years to maybe
come for me she instead told me to get
over it and stop being a [__] [__]
slash man up it was just a dog oh you
know what kind of household she grew up
in
what
not a good one just just a mean one yeah
yeah but okay all right can I just play
Devil's ad okay okay okay what if the
way what if the way he cried was kind of
we don't know how he was crying you
don't know because he's presenting it
and we're assuming it's just like a
little like like yeah yeah what if he
got an ugly ass cry yeah yeah you know
he's sitting there playing games he just
for like for like 10 days straight too
you know like for way too long
[Laughter]
stop crying
yeah we don't know my fiance is a micro
penis okay
wow it's almost a relief just to write
it down
IRL I've not told a single person not
anyone in my family not my bestie
I really have known to vent too I'm
thankful for this subreddit okay
[__] what's the suburb I have no one
to vent to True off my chest okay yeah
obvious obviously it's not a deal
breaker for me I want to spend the rest
of my life with him he is an amazing man
treats me so well highly intelligent he
is tall very good looking and fit he's
basically the whole package and I'm so
proud to be with him except for the
package his dick yeah he is three inches
hard and very thin
very thin
three inches Hearts he's like a
cigarette yeah cigarette [__]
basically the size of my dude basically
the size of my thumb
dang damn
wow
nice yeah
beautiful
the one area in this world he is
insecure about
it was definitely a shock for me at
first uh we do have sex often
pretty much every day without fail he
has magical hands and tongue and he is
very enthusiastic lover making what the
he's a very dude sorry she typed this
weird he is a very enthusiastic lover
dash making sure I finish every time oh
okay so he's a giver problem then he has
a tremendous imagination we we do use
toys
uh dildo sleeves strap-ons from time to
time it's all good leaves
um the [__] is a sleeve
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
that she used for cows yeah that's
exactly
um
now here's the real get off my chest he
would ask me if I ever miss a bigger
wiener oh I don't have it in my heart to
tell him absolutely yes
oh
I was always a very sexual being and I
was always very orgasmic from PIV
um penis and vagina
no
um
PC gaming in Vegas in Vegas yeah oh
right I absolutely Miss coming from PIV
yeah me too honestly I love PC gaming in
Vegas I come from that all the time yeah
I I absolutely crave that fulfilling
that I don't get now I wake up and just
crave it
uh it's not a deal breaker because I
love him he's an amazing man blah blah
blah I feel so bad the world is unfair
I would read on Reddit about men being
so sad and insecure over their average
wieners
um you're insecure over six inches shut
the [__] up
uh whoever or whatever I'm part of the
pro I'm part of the problem myself I was
the girl who previously bragged her
girlfriends about how well endowed my ex
is now I'm in the situation I'm in it's
funny how the world works I gotta go
talk to Kelsey about that post
where the [__] are you posting about me
I didn't know you had a Reddit account